pollution and cars and trucks to boost
fuel economy standards which are going
to be announcing very soon upping the
mileage requirement on that for the
minimum miles requirement
but that's not all
the bipartisan infrastructure law which
the folks behind me are the reason why
that occurred i signed provides billions
of dollars for a nationwide network of
500 000 charging stations 500 000
and will and with electric school buses
by the way down to north carolina you
should see the factory down there these
buses they have electric vehicles it has
a platform folks from me to you about
that thick weighs about 60 zillion
pounds no engine nothing else that's it
and but it's all electric all electric
and guess what we're going to eliminate
tens of thousands of diesel school buses
which pollute the air and pollute the
lungs
and look the industry this industry and
union workers are all stepping up
there's a lot more
here in washington state you're going to
triple the federal commitment to your
link we're going to triple the federal
commitment to your linked light rail
system speeding progress and the largest
transit
as my colleagues in the senate will
recall i was referred to as mr amtrak
i've taken over 1 million 200 000 miles
in amtrak committee commuting every
single day you think i'm joking for 36
years every single day the senate was in
session to go home and see my kids and
uh
but
the folks you know it's a simple
proposition most people don't realize it
given a choice
to go from point a to point b and rail
electric grail
or drive your automobile if you can get
there fast as fast or faster on rail you
take the rail
the estimates take will take millions of
vehicles off the road
the largest transit construction project
in the country that runs entirely on
clean energy
the bipartisan infrastructure law
provides 66 billion dollars
it's passed 66 billion dollars
for freight rail 39 billion for public
transit
10.6 billion for clean electric buses
and 2.5 billion for clean ferries on my
coast of delaware and out here for you
all
this will take millions of cars worth of
pollution off the road and get people to
places quicker
you know look i i i think one amtrak
train carries as many passengers i know
the statistics has six lanes of a major
interstate highway that's how many
passenger carriers look it matters
we saw on new standards we set new
standards we slashed methane and brought
over 100 nations together when i was at
the at at at at the big meeting we had
in europe 100 nations around the globe
and i got them to i there's two things i
was able to accomplish one i got a
pledge a pledge from 100 i think 144 of
them that they would eliminate methane
and do the same thing we're doing to
keep it it's the most damaging of all
the pollutants that are going up we also
set new standards
for super polluting hfc emissions
remember the big fight we had i know
because when i almost lost an election
because the dupont company makes the
long story anyway
um but look we set new standards for
cleaner cement he says what are you
talking about joey this is probably only
audience understand cleaner cement
cement is an incredible pollutant
an incredible pollutant and it matters
because cement is responsible for eight
percent of the global climate emissions
cement i gotta admit you as long as i've
been involved in this until two years
ago i didn't know that
and we're delivering across the country
lots of folks have promised it by but my
administration is actually delivering
revitalizing communities across
appalachia
look folks
uh i come from uh scranton pennsylvania
where i was raised the reason i got to
delaware is cold died my dad was not in
the coal mines he was in sales but the
whole economy died
and uh you know you can understand why
in places like west virginia and
southeastern pennsylvania and why people
were worried about doing away with coal
you know but it's their jobs they wonder
what they're going to do but guess what
the bipartisan infrastructure bill
the law is going to help us cap and seal
abandoned mines
now there's thousands of abandoned mines
cap and seal them they're no longer
going to see pollution in the air of the
water the law is putting abandoned mine
workers to work at the same salary they
were working digging the mines in the
first place there's several thousand of
these wells that have to be capped and
they have to harvest the energy and
they're going to get paid so we've
provided alternatives they're
manufacturing and installing solar
panels where they once dug for coal
look
here out here in the west we're
re-powering retired power plants and
cleaning it clean hydrogen and advanced
nuclear making them economic cubs again
and in the heartland and the fields that
feed our country we're planting
cover crops to
pull carbon out of the air now out of
the atmosphere
you know they're they're becoming carbon
sinks
look across the country we set the first
ever national conservation goal and
protecting more land and water than any
other administration and record in our
first year because we can do it and now
the farmers are beginning to realize
if i put things in conservation i get
paid for putting cover crops down that
absorb carbon it makes sense to me it
keeps the land open and it makes the
environment much better and they get
paid for it and they should get paid for
their land
we're protecting natural wonders and
cultural treasures national monuments i
remember a little girl came up to me
with her
i don't know where how it happened but i
was walking outside and a woman came up
with a little girl and said she said mr
president
please protect bazias
i said i beg your pardon honey
said please protect bears ears i said
bears ears
she said yes and i knew what bears ears
was because i've tried to take my kids
in almost every national park
and i said okay honey she said promise
me
promise me
and we did
bears ears for us like this longest boy
and by the way we got some of the
conservative republicans to support it
in this day we got some support for it
and now we're working to restore the
salmon runs here in the northwest
look we're putting america on the
cutting edge we've approved the first
commercial scale offshore wind project
in federal waters which has already
broken ground with u.s workers and u.s
steel going to be building these
facilities by the way i was up in in
colorado and looking at the facilities
we had there you know we now have
we now have windmills that the blades
and those windmills
102
yards long hear me
102
yards long
they can be placed way out in the ocean
and you know
and by the way i made it clear to my
friends up in uh
nantucket in that area
i don't wanna hear any more about you
don't like looking at them
they're pretty
but seriously it's incredible the
breakthroughs are to make it once you
tell a nation
that we can do this go do it it's
amazing what happens it's amazing what
happens
we've launched the first ever commercial
flight powered by 100 100 sustainable
aviation fuel lifted off with fuel grown
here in america grown in america we set
the first net zero commitments for u.s
steel companies and now we're rewarded
for clean air clean production through
our first ever international
carbon-based trade deal which makes
clean american steel cheaper to buy than
dirty steel from other countries and
we're making it clear to the rest of the
world that's what we're going to do
we put environmental injustice at the
center of what we do addressing the
disproportionate health environmental
and economic impacts that have been born
primarily by communities of color places
too often left behind i grew up when
when cole died in scranton i moved we
moved to delaware my dad had grown up we
moved to a little steel town called
clemont delaware which was right at arch
that goes up into the pennsylvania area
there and it's near a place called
marcus hook where there were more at the
time more oil for refineries than in
houston than houston because of 10
million people in that delaware valley
up there
and i we when we went to a small little
school
that was about
a mile from the apartment complex we
lived in and a little school called holy
rosary and i you couldn't walk to school
because although it was a four-lane
access highway it was just too dangerous
to cross some of the streets and my
mother would get in and when it came
spring i mean it came in the fall this
is the god's truth
and you get in the car and a little
frost on the window
turn on the windshield wiper that'd be
an oil slick not a joke
i have asthma and 80 of the people who
in fact we grew up with have asthma
that's what you call a fence line
community
i understand what it's like
i don't we only live there i went to
school there for 12 years
but i didn't live there that whole time
my generic point is you take a look my
state used to be thank god it's no
longer had the highest cancer rate of
any state in the nation because we have
fence line communities going down route
9 going down along the delaware river
major facilities oil plants and the like
and the people that get hurt
are the people who live on the other
side of those fences i made a commitment
they're the people are going to get
helped as we move this they're the
people where the money's going to go to
help their neighborhoods their and this
bipartisan forest law gives communities
the money they need to get forever
chemicals pfaz
off
out of the water they're deadly deadly
and a lot of us responsible because
we the government
and the fa and and and the military has
engaged in activities so we didn't
realize how it dated over the years but
we're going to get rid of it all we
started replacing 100
100 of all the lead pipes and poison
that poison our water in america
four hundred thousand schools and day
care centers the kids can't turn on that
water without getting worried about
whether there's lead in in that water
ten million homes in america and here in
this city in this state because every
american every child should be able to
turn on a faucet and drink clean water
which will also create thousands of good
paying jobs for plumbers and pipefitters
and others
look look
all you gotta do is look around cities
and states are acting businesses are
acting i'm acting we need congress to
act as well and the people behind me are
pushing congress hard
they're pushing congress hard
falling in the past new investments and
tax credits aimed directly lowering cost
her families look you talk about you
know a couple there's only two senators
occasionally don't vote with me
that's right right
literally
48 they talk about the split in the
democratic party
there's virtually no split in the
democratic party we just happen to have
50 presidents
you know you have 50 senators and 50
democrats 50 republicans any one can
change the dynamic right
but all kidding aside 48 of my
democratic colleagues in the senate vote
with me 94 of the time
so it's not like we have a split but we
don't have we have virtually no
republicans
there's some we get up to as many as
seven or eight will vote
this ain't your father's republican
party
not not a joke
all you got to do is look what has been
played out played
this morning
about the tape that was released
anyway
you know but they're all
getting aside this is the maga party now
it's you know you got the
the senator from texas and others these
these guys are a different breed of cat
they're not like what i served with for
so many years
and the people who know better
are afraid why act correctly because
they know they'll be primary
i've had i won't mention any my promise
they never would and i won't but up to
six come to me and say joe i want to be
with you on such and such but i can't
i'll be primary
i'll lose my race
i'll lose my race
so folks we're gonna this is gonna start
to change
look
that bill that we talked about that is
the infrastructure bill there were two
pieces of it it was one bill initially
and that bill had about eight hundred
thousand eight hundred million dollars
in it for environmental related issues
well the one that didn't pass the part
that didn't pass yet is one that has 531
million dollars for environmental
radiation we got a lot done though
in the bill that passed called the
infrastructure bill that has to do with
the environment
including tax credits for purchases of
electric and fuel cell vehicles
now
no we're used but you're going to save
typical driver about eighty thousand
eight
eighty dollars a month from not having
to pay gas at the pump tax credits for
folks to buy solar panels and heat pumps
more efficient windows saving each an
average of 500 a year to do this just
making your home tighter so you don't
leak the heat and leak the air
conditioning you're going out you know
and my pen is ready
my pen is ready to sign i'm anxious to
sign this get some of these bills to my
desk and we can't forget
you can't forget that achieving our
ambitious climate goals is going to
require
nature itself to play a role you know
if you compare the map of north america
in 1620 and we have some of these maps
with america today you'll see
much of our devas how much we've
devastated our forest
i mean it used to be if you look from
the atlantic coast almost to the
mississippi river was heavy forest
we took it all down over those years
that's why today i'm signing an
executive order
to conserve our forests that do so much
to protect us
you know
our forests are our planet's lungs
they literally are recycling and cycling
co2 out of the atmosphere that's what
they do
by the way more the i spent time down in
the amazon
and in colombia and in brazil
and guess what
more
carbon is taken out of the air
in the amazon
that carbon sink than every bit of
carbon that is generated on a daily
basis in the entire united states from
every source
so what we should be doing and i'm
trying to get done
they're not going to make me like this
we should be paying the brazilians not
to cut down their forest we got to cut
ours down
we got to cut ours down
we got the benefit of it because we've
got these third world countries not
third world some are
in africa and in and in
south america we gotta the the
industrial countries have to help
scientists estimate that the protection
and restoration of our natural lands and
waters can provide more than one-third
of the solution to climate change just
just that no if we did nothing else so
today i'm about to sign an executive
order to strengthen our forest on
federal lands
and make them and the local economies
they support more resilient in the face
of wildfires
i've flown over every major wildfire in
this country with fema since not every a
couple i didn't but the vast majority of
them and it's devastating i've seen it
from helicopters with fema just flying
over here in idaho i didn't get to go to
oregon california it's absolutely
devastating so we're going to work with
state and local and tribal governments
to map catalog and then conserve old
growth forests on our public lands
these as far as
we'll do this days of the forest stores
sequester incredible amounts of carbon
and help us fight climate change the
forests that are
are home to majestic trees like the ones
here in the uh this park's magnificent
forest
you know the executive order i'm going
to sign is going to make good on the
international forest protection
commitments from the proposed line made
in scotland at glasgow 26. i got 140
countries to sign up and say
together
we represent 90 of the world's forest
and this includes our own effort to
crack down on trafficking of illegal
logged wood and prod and products like
the ones illegally deforesting areas
around the world in addition to that
i put in the bipartisan infrastructure
bill
a a
that we're gonna plant 1.2 billion trees
1.2 billion trees across this country to
begin the vital work of reforest in
america it makes sense and it also makes
a big difference
including in our cities and on our city
streets
the executive order also recognizes when
it comes to protecting our communities
from floods and storms
nature can help us as well for example
when it comes to stopping flooding
sometimes a wetland is more effective
than a sea wall i live along a state
where it's only average three feet above
sea level the state of delaware the
delaware river the delaware bay the
atlantic ocean
well you saw what happened by the way
down in the gulf you saw what happened
in louisiana when they had that you know
it matters whether or not there's a
wetlands they're significantly more
consequential than sea walls
in order to help bring more of those
nature-based solutions into our planet
we have to move quickly and with this
executive order on earth day we're also
showing this moment of maximum threat
and urgency can also be a moment of
enormous hope and enormous opportunity
you know that we you know that we carry
in heart and mind the image of the ideal
place the right place the one true home
known or unknown actually visionary
i know you all feel it you wouldn't be
sitting here and cold with your coats
not on
if you did
so i'm not going to sign this executive
order and uh
i think we're going to make i just think
this is the beginning of a new day and
we're going to just have to overtake the
opposition on this i really mean it so
thank you all for being here i'm going
to sign
[Music]
strengthening the nation's forest
communities and local economies and it's
all about planting about a billion 200
million trees so
and by the way anybody bring their
shovels
all right
is this a state park or is this a city
park city city park mr mayor yes sir
right here
thank
and by the way
you know the two of the department of
interior now
[Applause]
oh yeah but i tell you what this is